you're not afraid to describe yourself
as having some geekish qualities i'm way
i'm like super nerd i'm like crazy did
you ever try and because a lot of people
go through a phase where they try and
deny who they are yes yes yes i tried
when i left school i was the ultimate
school nerd and then i went to
university college and i tried to
reinvent myself like i wore a lot of
black and i just sort of did a lot of
you know kind of moody leaning
do you know what i mean and just you
know i would have a cigarette i wouldn't
liked it but i would just
look like i was having a lot of
existential thoughts
on day one i arrived like that and i
just tried to look really interesting
and i was in like um a hall of residence
we call it like a dorm i got like 30
people and i came back like two weeks in
and i walked down and my dorm room was
open
there's a little crowd of people and i
sort of peered over the top easily done
for me and i appeared over the top and
the cleaning lady who was maybe like
five foot was in there and she was
wearing my size 15 shoes
and she was just dancing around
[Applause]
i'm like
you have size 15 shoes 15.
10 and like 10 or 15 people from my from
my college were just laughing they saw
me they were weeping with laughter and
it's not funny that's not a funny image
a woman wearing my shoes and you thought
you would establish this cool image and
it turns out everyone's just everyone's
already laughing at me like two weeks in
like do you
i swear to god it's not a funny image
it's not my shoes on a lady is not a
funny image would you could you yeah
sure just you stepped behind there kate
do you mind me asking yeah right you're
not gonna mount me i'm not gonna go near
you don't worry
um
i like that you chose me over kate
beckinsale yeah i realized i made a
mistake tony yeah okay just just pop
those shoes on right all right yeah this
is not funny i guarantee there is
nothing amusing about this am i doing it
just pop them off you just walk out and
then do a little dance
there is nothing amusing about this
they're quite warm inside of course they
are of course they are yeah
clammy even yeah
just try to go around them
absolutely nothing i defy you to laugh
at this
i defy you to laugh at that
there's nothing that needs to know
[Applause]
have you done to this beautiful woman
you monster can i keep them all yeah
amazing don't get hurt please wear them
to an awards ceremony yeah
that will be fantastic it's like a
vehicle
now give him yours yeah
that's what we want to see
uh we have a clip here from life's too
short oh that's too short right yeah
this is a show we did i mean ricky and i
did thank you very much uh ricky gervais
and i did this show um thank you um uh
and it stars warrick davis warwick davis
um before we show the clips i think we
have to have a massive hand from
[Applause]